and now we have the amazing cara eastman
who's running for congress out of
nebraska's second district which i think
includes omaha that's right right
welcome cara
welcome welcome to yang speaks you and i
met when i was campaigning in iowa
um because for those of you who aren't
geographical
experts iowa and nebraska touch each
other
like right there yes and i i said this
then and i i
you were the most inspiring political
speaker i'd ever heard
talk so thank you for that it was it was
fun and you know politics isn't always
that much fun
politics is not that much fun but you've
been in the change-making
line of work for a long time you and i
bonded over the fact that you
also started and ran a non-profit that
did an incredible work in your case it
was a
children's non-profit based in nebraska
yep it's called omaha healthy kids
alliance it still exists but i'm no
longer there i was hired to start it in
2006
and our focus was originally was
eliminating childhood lead poisoning and
then eventually we grew into a green and
healthy housing organization
well your evolution is similar to mine
in that you run a nonprofit and you see
all these problems
uh in our communities and you think wow
someone should really do something about
that and then you're like i guess it
might be me
because after you work
as a nonprofit leader you kind of get a
sense as to
uh frankly like the need for different
solutions to solve the problems you're
tackling every day
that's right well and and these are
problems that can be fixed
if we have because we have the resources
to fix them in this country we just
don't have the political will
yeah well you're changing that tell us
about your race in nebraska for people
who don't know that much about it
and also and you can do this in order
when did you first hear about universal
basic income
well um i heard about it from you on the
campaign trail
[Laughter]
so there's that but um yeah it's it's an
exciting race here
in the second district all eyes are on
us because
in 2008 we gave an electoral college
vote to barack obama
in nebraska we split our electoral
college votes similar to maine
and so we have that one that some people
are saying could be
the deciding electoral college vote it's
a little terrifying to think about but
could be true
and biden is ahead in the polls and as
am i
and so we have a real opportunity to
elect the first woman to serve the
district
uh somebody i'm running against a trump
republican who's voted with him 93
of the time and also to give that
electoral college vote to get rid of
trump
while you are up it is very hard to beat
an incumbent tell us more
like it sounds like has this guy been in
congress for a long time
he's in his second term and you know i i
actually ran against him in 2018
and came up 1.9 short in one of the
closest races in the country
so we're back again and we've given
people four years to see him in action
and he's betrayed the district over and
over again
and they're looking for somebody who's
actually going to represent them
wow you're gonna make that that the
comeback it's like cara the return
you know like rocky two a little bit
like like the
the first race was rocky one we all know
what happens at the end of rocky too
rocky wins for those of you haven't seen
it
one reason why i'm thrilled to get you
into congress is that uh you are for
cash relief during the pandemic and
someone who's worked with families
the way you have um you would be for
cash relief because you understand the
good it would do
in the lives of so many people in your
district
that's right we have so many politicians
in office in particular on the
republican side
who do not seem to understand the needs
of regular working people
and that you know most of us are one
economic shortfall away from total
bankruptcy total annihilation of our
family and if that's in
in the form of hitting a pothole and
having your tires blow out
when you haven't you don't have the
money saved up to actually pay for that
which is challenging to do because it's
expensive
or getting laid off from your job and
now we see this in the middle of the
pandemic
where so many people have lost their job
and therefore lost their health care
so it's we need people in congress who
understand this
we need more working class people in
congress the average net worth of a
congress person right now is a million
dollars we need people who understand
this stuff
and i've had the honor of working in
non-profit organizations for over 20
years my world view is framed by the
clients that i've had the honor of
serving and i believe they deserve a
voice
so tell us about your race i mean you
came within a hair's breadth of winning
in 2018
and what are you seeing this time we're
seeing a lot of change with independents
in the district about a quarter of the
district are registered independents we
started our campaign this time by
knocking doors of independence in 2018
we knocked on 200
000 doors around the entire district
and so um and what we heard from
independents this time was their number
one priority was getting donald trump
out of office
so when we have a congress person who
has so heavily aligned himself with
trump
and with the republican party nebraskans
are pretty independent look we have a
unicameral
we've had we've actually been a prairie
progressive state in the past where we
had democrats as our governor as our
u.s senators and and i think a lot of
people have seen that the trump
administration's
failed promises have actually really
hurt nebraska especially in terms of our
agricultural economy
and especially in terms of that tax bill
which we know was not for regular
working people
i agree with you that independents right
now are looking up and saying we gotta
turn the page for our country trump has
to leave
and i think that's one reason why i am
so pumped
about your race and other races around
the country
that uh you have a wind at your back
this time
that i don't think has existed in my
recent memory
so we need to get behind candidates like
you and make sure that you
you win i i agree well and and when we
look at 2018
people talk about you know the fact that
it was great that we flipped the house
but
you know 84 of incumbent republicans in
that in the house kept their seat
so i i would not describe that as a blue
wave but i think that we can have
that this time expanding the house
majority flipping the senate and
obviously flipping the presidency
uh the the i'm optimistic about uh your
race and many other races car
i think the toughest thing is going to
be after you all get to congress is
trying to get that institution working
um more efficiently and effectively than
it has been
in quite some time but it starts with
getting people like you in
having a non-profit leader like you
uh who's so close to your community in
congress
trying to craft policy would be such a
quantum leap forward uh and it is funny
like talking to you now i think
other people might have the same
impression um because
like you said most members of congress
at this point are
very affluent uh you know a lot of them
come from
business backgrounds and
backgrounds where they can plug into
like a network of money um and you come
from a very different background
it's very very grassroots driven
uh the fact that a candidate like you is
poised to make a bit of history
uh political history it sounds like in
nebraska uh
is such a great sign for 2020 what would
your top legislative priorities be
after you get sworn in because you're
going to win and you're going to get
sworn in 2021
aside from you know dealing with the
pandemic in a responsible
way that actually demonstrates
leadership and prevents human lives from
being lost
my two priorities are health care
fixing our broken health care system
we're just we have to start with
lowering prescriptions i'm running
because my mother was prescribed a 2500
pill that she couldn't afford to take
and i want to get money out of politics
so actually fighting corruption and
reforming our system and doing things to
stop the threats to our democracy i
think that that's incredibly important
probably now more than ever
so many people agree with you on those
priorities i love them
it's economic relief fixing our health
care system
and getting money out of politics slash
tying our politics to people
my proposal as you know was give
everyone 100 democracy dollars
so the goal would be to wash the
corporate money out
so it's not even quite get the money out
of politics it's more like tie the money
to what
ordinary people think um because right
now the number of people that donate to
political campaigns and if you're
someone who's donated to a campaign you
should know
that puts you in like the like maybe 10
of americans donate to political
campaigns it's probably risen this cycle
so let's call it 12 14 but that's still
um highly unusual so what could we get
that percentage up to
if everyone had 100 dollars and then
they said i'd like cara eastman
you know i'm going to i'm going to get
behind her and i've got 100 democracy
dollars to do so like what percentage do
you think we'd get up to
if everyone had 100 free dollars upwards
of 80
i mean i think people would actually get
engaged and get involved and
and one of the things that that struck
me and i don't ever hear anyone talking
about this so maybe we could
but when i first started running you
know they tell you like go to your
friends and family
ask for money right i did that like my
friends gave me fifty dollars it's
wonderful
but like what they mean is go to your
wealthy friends and family
and and go to corporate packs but when i
started looking at the lists
of people who donate to democrats in
our district 99.9
of those people were white people and it
was
shocking to me that we have so few
people of color who give to political
campaigns so so drill down that number
even more right
and and we know that especially for
wealthier donors they often get
prioritized in my campaign we
we run on a grassroots campaign our
average donation is incredibly low we
have thousands of donors
but that's not typical this is actually
pretty different for a district like
mine
and just different in general because
it's not just republicans that have done
this it's democrats as well
so we need to change the system
yeah your the numbers are very very um
damning in this regard so i said let's
say 10 of americans donate and
those 10 are donating 50 bucks because
that's what a normal person would do
if if you drill down to people who
donate over 250
which makes you like a more serious
donor that 10 drops quickly to like i
think it's one percent
[Laughter]
so and you're looking at the top uh
10th of one percent that give like the
max of 2800
um in a federal race uh and so when
you're given
fun fundraising uh direction
about running for congress you need to
raise 1.6 million on average to be
successful
uh and so if you do the math on that
like uh
it's hard to get there on like like 20
bucks you know you need like a lot of
people so they expect you to go
chase down the folks who can give you
thousands uh and that's the game
and we need to change the game so that
you have more representatives that
actually answer to
people that aren't in position to give
thousands of dollars
that's right and you don't we shouldn't
have candidates or
elected officials spending time doing
this this is not
how i mean you don't want your congress
person spending six hours a day raising
money
well you don't want that but
unfortunately is the norm uh lawrence
lester excited
a study that said that members of
congress spend 30 to 70 percent of their
work hours raising money
so that's six hours a day like that's
not an exaggeration that's not a car
just making it up i mean that's real uh
so cara if people want to get behind you
and help
push you to victory on november 3rd
where can they they find out about you
and how can they help
eastman for congress.com on twitter at
cara for congress kara with a k
facebook at eastman for congress or
instagram at cara for congress and
we can use all the help we need money we
need volunteers
we need people just to spread the word
on social media whatever you can do
right now
the value that gets generated the last
number of days is like a lot of things
in life where like a lot of the last
mile value
is the most important so it's not too
late to help cara
cara eastman nebraska second district
give help volunteer text bank phone bank
and
we're going to be in position to
celebrate cara's victory you're going to
be such an incredible member of congress
and i am pumped for it i'm pumped to be
a part of it
thank you that means a lot coming from
you i appreciate it
i appreciate you carl let's win thank
you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you